prior senator gene brooke
thank you
personally i am so
excited and grateful thank you
return
an african-american 240
more likely to die from pregnancy or
childbirth-related causes than white
women
indiana's infant mortality rate is the
seventh highest in the nation
and black ladies in indiana die
at 2.5 or two and a half times
the rate of white baby
this isn't okay
i am under our community
and i am angry
republicans not only continue to ignore
these real life and death situations for
families but particularly poor white
families and families of color but are
instead
winning these dangers by removing
abortion as a maternal health care
option
i am extremely concerned for the lives
of women
total abortion bans similar to the one
proposed by indiana republicans in
senate bill 1 will lead to a 21
inc
number pregnancy related deaths overall
and a 33 increase among black women
this does not include the deaths
resulting from attempted abortions and
potentially dangerous unlicensed
facilities
lack of abortion access in a state with
an already abysmal
system
will kill women
what republicans want to do by placing a
very restrictive ban on abortion access
will have a devastating effect on the
lives of women
as a woman and a black woman
i reject what i see as harassment and
terrorism of women our right to
reductive freedoms
i stand ready to continue the fight to
protect the health and safety of all
hoosier women thank you thank you
senator bro um and finally uh
representative carson thank you so much
for joining us today thank you
well mr g
we appreciate leadership we certainly
are honored to have the vice president
here uh we know the supreme court with
this decision in dobbs versus jackson's
women's health organization they've
effectively stripped away americans
freedom to make their own health care
decisions including those about abortion
every situation in pregnancy is
different
we trust people not politicians to make
their own decisions about their health
lives and bodies
for republicans overturning role is only
the beginning their very extreme agenda
includes plans to criminalize abortion
across our country and next they will
take aim
at other basic human rights including
how democrats in congress and in indiana
are fighting this radical and reckless
gop agenda and this is a crisis
situation
and the devastating impacts are being
felt across our country so we appreciate
you mr giaquinta the black caucus and
all of my hoosier representatives and
legislators here as well as president
and who are from leadership
that's the mark or truly to take time
out of her very busy schedule to come to
the great hoosier state and stand with
hoosiers and americans thank you thank
you represent carson um
madam vice president it is so
uh an honor to have you here with us
today it really is and um
uh
uh just we were just together a couple
weeks ago having a similar conversation
and i just want to say that i really do
appreciate
your leadership uh the president's
leadership on this issue
and um really for all that you are doing
to fight
for reproductive rights for women
it's an honor to have you here
thank you again for joining us thank you
thank you representative gian clinton
the representative came to visit with me
in washington d.c
to talk about
all of you
and the people of this beautiful state
uh as from the conversation that he also
made an invitation for me to come and
visit with you
and so i'm here today
to thank you
because the people at this table are not
only local and state leaders you are
national leaders
on the front lines of one of one of the
most critical issues facing
one representative carson for joining me
and flying in with me today um and for
your leadership in washington dc
representing the people of the state of
indiana
as has been said
the united states supreme court
in the dobbs decision
took
continual right
that had been recognized
from the people of
america the women
of america
let's contemplate what that means in and
of itself
that in a land
that was founded
on the important
principles
of freedom
and liberty
that such a thing would happen
and not without grave
consequence
so that is the context
which we meet
and fight
this has created a health care crisis
in america
and as has been said indiana has already
been on the forefront
of this very issue
as representative pryor
described one
more
publicized and well-known
cases in terms of what this issue means
to real people including children
and i will tell you around our country
we are seeing indeed many states
since the dobbs decision in attempting
before
criminalize health professionals
to punish women
states that are
creating no exception
for rape or incest
and i am a former prosecutor
i specialize in crimes
against women and children i specialized
in child sexual assault cases
the idea in some states
after a child or a woman or a man but in
particular on this case of abortion
a woman or a child would have endured
such an act of violence and then to
suggest that she
would not have the autonomy
and authority to make a decision
about what happens to her body
is outrageous
so these are the parameters of this
issue of course
there are more
i would also say that on this issue
one does not have to abandon your faith
or your beliefs
to agree
that the government
should not be making this decision for
her
an individual should be able to choose
based on their personal beliefs
and the dictates of their faith
but the government should not be telling
an individual
what to do especially as it relates to
one of the most intimate
and personal decisions a woman could
make
here in indiana
i am here to support these
extraordinary and courageous leaders
and in particular on this day
where indiana
is the first state since the job
decision to convene a special session
to propose
a law that includes based on what is
being proposed
what essentially will be
a ban on abortion
for women because do be clear
and maybe some people need to actually
learn
how a woman's body works
but when you understand how a woman's
body works
you will understand that the parameters
that are being proposed
mean that for the vast majority of women
by the time she realizes she is pregnant
she will effectively be prohibited
from having access
to reproductive health care that would
allow her to choose
what happens to her body
so
these are the realities
the president
has signed an executive order to protect
women's access to abortion medication
and has taken action to protect the
constitutional right to interstate
travel
and we will do everything
in our power
to
follow through on those commitments
what we know is that
this issue
of access to reproductive care
and a woman's right to make decisions
about her body
relate to other risks
that have been posed
by the dobbs decision
we are looking at
an interpretation of the constitution
that suggests thomas at the part out
loud
that this puts at risk an individual's
work to make decisions about
contribution
puts at risk
the right to marry the person you
love so when we discuss this issue and
when we contemplate what it means
understand
it could have a profound
impact
on just about everyone in our country
who has any association
or interest or concern
about these various issues
so for all of those reasons
what these leaders at this table are
doing right now to stand in defense
of the women
of this state
is by extension to stand for the rights
of women
throughout our country
the president and i take seriously
our work
that is about protecting the health the
safety and the well-being
of the women of america
and that includes
the women of indiana
and that is why i'm here and i look
forward to our conversation and i thank
you all again for your leadership
madam vice president do you support a
[Applause]
madam vice president do you support a
public health emergency on abortion
madam vice president do you support a
ban on a public health emergency on
abortion
thank you so much
guys
you